[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
up
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
alone
[Music]
hey uh
reach the wizards
the united states is often called the
great melting pot
but it's a country that's struggled with
race relations throughout its history
and still does today does america have a
race problem
all the evidence says yes it's a history
of oppression
because of the raw ugly racism and
ethno-nationalism
of our president
i've been all over the world america is
one of the most diverse
but yet um racist countries there is
i mean you just have an agenda over here
but i don't talk to racism
oh i don't talk to idiots you all have a
great day just proves
what the majority of america thinks
about y'all systemic racism
is real in america
i think it's people that are racist is
not a system you can't generalize people
[Music]
they've done this black lives matter
this doesn't they all do you're right
no not all of them no they do not say
[Music]
that
[Music]
it's june which marks louder with
crowders fifth annual
cultural appropriation month where we
take you across the globe to learn about
and appreciate all the cultures this
world has to offer
this week their opera house is pointier
than yours
it's australia
yes glad to be with you i have not seen
that introduction
where he punches the kangaroo in the
face and i was not a proof
that's wrong he's right after my
daughter oh
wait in front of the croc all the time
bindi like michael jackson on a balcony
so uh i can't do that all show oh my god
there's a lot to hold up please we ran
out of cultures that weren't wide enough
um we figured australia that'll work
because too appropriate is to appreciate
and uh we have jaco willing on the show
today
ooh we do we have the jocko willing on
the show we have some fast facts here
for us
yeah uh but first my well hold on we'll
be talking about the atlanta
ruling of course we'll be talking about
all the black lives matter we'll be
talking about uh
not all lives matter all the black lives
matter right yes do not know
get it correct yeah let's be really
clear can't say that because racism
is bad right
my producer says right don't you indeed
she's my producer
everywhere it's really just a talk from
the city clause at the store with a
little jiggly crook
and um my lawyer bill richmond is here
how are you sir hello friends
that is an actual knife be careful with
it didn't have a prop
no nope that's real uh by the way remind
me uh
quarterback garrett as a producer we
need to um either purchase
uh airsoft replicas or blanks gotcha
because the guy who
worked here before the guy who had that
he's no longer with us let's make sure
that doesn't happen again
uh audio weight is here gerald a is here
what's the line of the day
the wine of the day is an aussie wine
pen folds ben389 really do they make
good wine they do
fantastic wow so bad costumes great ones
true what they say what what is that it
australia though a colony entirely
founded by rapists and felons
can still make good alcohol yes i've
heard that before
which is what you want with rapists and
felons well you need it just liquor them
up yo well yes
roll the dice uh australia facts as we
move on
uh while famous for kangaroos and koalas
the most common mammal in australia is
the hemsworth
contrary to pop he's the only one who
cleaned up that
show that was the all-female
ghostbusters you must ruin my childhood
instead you just ruined bindis uh
contrary to popular belief not all
aussies are racist but all racists
are aussies you can do the math on that
uh unlike america
australian culture is going down the
toilet clockwise
that's physics not a minute really not a
factor of reinforcement australia was
established as a penal colony for
rapists
uh murderers and venomous spiders but
that's just oh
i don't think i'm telling you anything
that you don't know
it always goes back to this i guess the
question of the day i don't you've seen
the video i uploaded this morning but i
do want to ask you guys before we move
on i do want your opinions on what
happened with atlanta
and uh officer rolfe over there uh
going into election uh we might actually
be doing just good morning month club
because a lot of you people have been
tuning in watching good morning
club and we'll be doing the elect the
streams for all the debates all the town
halls which are like two or three hours
yeah so i want to know if you guys think
that's a good plan where we go
doing good morning my club more often
monday through thursday and instead of
doing the thursday show at night we can
actually prepare to do the live
debate fact check streams let us know
because uh we're surprised at the people
who tune in to good morning
does this mean more cnn or less cnn it
depends
yeah more yeah please don't make me
bored by the way steve irwin that was a
man
steve irwin i have never been more
impressed with a human being i watched
one time him jump into open water
yeah with a crocodile salt water
crocodile into open water it was crazy
just
like a death roll and they're just
spiraling like it's fantasia
the damn in the middle of the water
that's way more impressive than a swamp
they're not he's not grounded on
anything no
synchronized swimming no it's amazing
yes exactly love animals enough to do
that secret
what do you think bindi look organic
together
so uh he's always in the way we'll bring
him back
we want jaco to get the full experience
yeah you have to
uh first though before we move on with
the show um let's check in with the
current state of western civilization
the slaps i love it
i love it i love it
i love it he loves it in theory
yeah he's not really ironic one
cameraman is clearly gay
i love it
[Music]
good news is advertising executives took
note and now racism is over so
it's a problem of the past
accurate by the way the aunt jemima
thing
what was that i said i'm glad we solved
it yeah and uncle ben's uncle ben's is
gonna be
uh takashi 6'9
just him dry humping a miner and
featured on youtube home page
uh sorry this is not for kids because we
have to acknowledge it's actually going
on in our country right now and
that's it i can't imagine that one there
are cultural differences
of course that happen uh but these riots
i can't imagine
15 years ago anyone doing that outside
of a strip club right yeah
you'd be arrested yeah well it's a woman
it's a woman servicing herself in front
of police officers
it's unreal to me and the lady on the
bottle the the model of the aunt jemima
she was she was born a slave she became
a free woman
she and by the way it doesn't matter if
sanchez was a real they probably she
probably they wouldn't care anyways the
model could have been a lady who may
kick ass pancakes they wouldn't care
like if you could bring her back from
the dead you think she she what
you took my face
[Laughter]
bring her back from the dead be like
yeah you know what people wanted to take
away that
wait hold on a second y'all mean that
i've been selling i've been selling
that i've been selling that much syrup
people bought it so the country must
have changed right and y'all it's like a
majority black no it's only like 12
percent
no we also had a black president oh okay
so at that point maybe y'all like there
was a switch like the south and the
north and then they moved like no it was
actually white people who elected
uh a black president
and y'all go y'all gonna remove my face
that's that's my brand that is called
brand protection [ __ ]
you know what the real problem you all
want to talk about now i'm a free woman
i'm a free strong black woman out here
now
and i am making millions of dollars and
white mothers have a problem with that
let you know what a problem i have i
have a problem with that that's not even
real maple syrup
you put some corn syrup in that muffi
and food coloring
just flavor i had to get the real sh i
had to get
harriet tubman's train go to canada
bring that [ __ ] back
you know one second don't take me and
take my face off the [ __ ]
that's how you honor her yeah a race the
wealthy free black woman
yeah and feature the twerk
in other social justice news uh the card
game
sorry about all the sensor buttons for
the first half that's a rough transition
there
fingers getting tired and watch people
are trying to get me in trouble
for doing a voice now it's black voice
you can't do black voice well post more
than black voice you can
i don't think that that's a cultural
thing with australia you'd have to do it
accurately which i think i don't know
did they scalp
did they have they didn't
[Laughter]
by the way also we'll be talking about
chokeholds with jacob willink and i will
be choking audio weight now
i'll show you what a chokehold actually
is spoiler alert
i'm a big fan
[Laughter]
me too wait wait hold on hold on you're
saying the police say y'all don't want
to have guns you don't want cops
you don't want to have tasers and they
can't choke them on the
[Laughter]
that's right sassy she wouldn't say that
hear your pancakes load it
jesus save me i'm serving need my
pancake don't take my face off this
pancakes
i don't know why i'm making my
god imagine that imagine aunt brings her
pancakes into wonderful syrup and you go
send it back yes
i know i didn't hear your white asses in
this book
where it used to be called it used to be
called uh appreciating like
right yeah southern food now it's well
racist if you don't like tacos races if
you do like tacos yeah
i'm taco neutral taco bell cancelled
don't talk about them oh okay in other
social justice news
uh the card game magic the gathering we
didn't even get to a single story again
it's just aunt jemima we'll get there
magic the gathering has now removed
racist cards from the game
so uh one of the cards this was a story
that we have from forbes one such racist
card is actually what's called the
invoke prejudice card
uh also remove the pradesh gypsies card
and the lose ten points for using your
right turn blinker when merging left
card
so that was one that seems pretty cute
that was obvious and
dry
i don't know i don't know but in other
news uh liberals somehow found a way to
make magic the gathering
less fun ah you didn't think it could
happen
they did it they found a way our art
just reflects reality
you can say it i can't yep that's right
what was it
20 20 y'all [ __ ] asians course
i wouldn't even get a horse in the
bucket
so by the way a deer also speaking
because everything has been black lives
matter
atlanta and unfortunately right now
because the racial division in the
country
really i think brings us together it
does it seems uh
a deer ran into a black lives matter
protest in new jersey and and seriously
injured a woman and this was a story
everywhere
now obviously that's a tragic story i
believe that she's expected to make a
full recovery
some people uh have suspected this might
be
a retaliation for a recent viral world
star
video
[Music]
[Music]
i like that it's one guy in the woods
how many people can you fit in the woods
otherwise you'll scare them off that's
true he has a pretty steady hand i
appreciate the uh cinematography
really he's a documentarian yeah yeah
wait was that michael barton
oh no it's the same guy who did grizzly
man
[Laughter]
grizzly man i just
it's funny when we wrote that bit we had
to watch the original bambi scene yeah
we were in you know we were in the
writer's room and you could hear a pin
drop because we always got really sad
yeah this is a kid's film
you never see it though that's a rough
movie yeah it is a rough film uh
finally by the way uh before we move on
to some of the more serious news in jack
willing
wages for chinese trolls have dropped by
60 percent
oh the standard pay was 50 cents before
now it's been cut to as little as
20 cents so this news obviously is being
monitored closely and has caused serious
concern for taiwanese orcs
so they're not happy about it yeah
that explains my recent paycheck
darn this one's this is an episode for
the books
[Laughter]
as long as it stays i look forward to
the conversation with the powers that
beat alphabet
um it's okay we haven't quite crossed
the line of takashi we're 69.
no we haven't choked out a fan in
houston and beat our girlfriend without
mercy but then again we haven't
featured on trending so yeah yeah you
know
tomato sex offender uh so
the man arrested uh by the way for let's
have you guys seen this this this was a
clip that did go viral while we're
talking about all the stuff that's been
going on this man
uh not trigger one i hate these now
reappropriate trigger trigger warning
means like a trigger warning you might
have ptsd because
someone put male or female on your
your test no there's an actual warning
for people who might be
underage like who might be watching um
though in retrospect that should have
been before the lady was masturbating in
front of her law enforcement
well you know better late than never i
was focusing on getting in character
yeah so um if you haven't seen this this
is a video that actually took place in
new york city of a man knocking out a
uh elderly very very woman yeah
let's watch this
[Music]
yep now why is this important because it
does provide some context here as we get
into the uh the cop charged with murder
that that guy who you saw there he is a
registered sex offender who's been
arrested more than 100 times
wow that's got to be a record i don't
think it's a record how do you get
arrested a hundred times and not be in
jail
i don't maybe he maybe he's from
australia
that is what they do he just said no no
i have no i have no idea i have no idea
and my question you see that so let's
say you're there on the street let's say
that's your grandma yeah right
and people die all the time from getting
hit in the head that's why i support
some kind of actual physical submission
whether it's
whether it's a neck restraint or
something that doesn't involve striking
somebody forcefully
let's say that's your grandmother catch
your grandmother she gets she's going to
recover but she hit her in the fire
hydrant it's your grandmother you go
whoa whoa hey hey what's going on and
the guy starts coming at you or the guy
starts running away
off to another old lady yeah and you try
and stop him
but you can't you can't use a firearm to
defend your grandmother
you can't use a firearm to stop him he's
like well okay hope for the best maybe
he'll run off into oh and
it's an apartment complex there are a
lot of old ladies there well
no way it's an old good news is they're
almost all gone from kovid so little
damage he can do there you go
right i don't know why this offends me
so much too i know that there are other
crimes
offensive old lady was knocked out i
think i can guess
if you'd let me finish this like
murderers right like they they offend me
too but for some reason when people pick
on they offend me as well your instinct
to stop him originally stephen was
correct yes
offend me but for some reason when
people pick on
elderly and defenseless people like it
offends me more than i think it should
like it's
bad it's horrible obviously but it's
like i just want to beat the crap out of
them
really jews yeah he deserves he deserves
to have he deserves to have his
head punched by someone who can do it
repeatedly maybe 100
for each arrest it's like a birthday
thing and a pinch to grow an inch
and a nine millimeter just kidding just
kidding um
from atlanta and i did a video on this
this morning i had to get it out of my
system
yeah uh was charged with felony murder
right felony murder we went through this
before uh obviously you saw the clip
where the man was arrested beat the hell
out of two cops stole the taser pointed
at them
here's here's the thing is felony murder
can you explain felony murder people who
don't know bill and don't get too legal
easy
sure there's uh murder where you're
trying to you want the stupid
explanation
i'll go let me just come on down here no
murders when you're
you've obviously caught someone to die
um and you've either attended that or
there's different levels of you know the
intent or whether you knew it was going
to happen sure and a felony murder is
just
someone died while you were committing a
felony so like a
like an armed robber you're robbing a
bank and maybe you went in and didn't
mean to [ __ ] but then someone dies that
would be a felony even if they died of a
heart attack right uh because they are
during the commission of a felony so
here you know there's a number of
charges they haven't released all of the
documents they haven't given all of the
information yet even the georgia bureau
of investigation has said well we
haven't even finished our investigation
but they went ahead and said 11 charges
one of which is felony felony murder so
that means that the officer was
committing a felony
before he shot the man who stole his gun
and supposed to be aimed at him right
right what in the world could that
felony possibly well let's
watch uh it from the local d.a also
um walking version of the the guy who
used to broom
uh between the segments and rocky and
bull winkle you'll see what i mean he
looks like a human version of that
the d.a statement on the felony murder
mr brooks on the night of this incident
was called brush the room
that the officer may not use deadly
force
to prevent escape unless the officer has
probable cause to believe
that the suspect poses an immediate
threat
of death okay or of serious
physical injury to that officer okay the
city of atlanta sops
in fact prohibit officers from firing
tasers
at someone who is running away so the
city of atlanta says you cannot
even fire a taser at someone who's
running
away so you certainly can't fire a gun a
handgun
at someone who is running away so he
said that the officers were under no
fear of not only death but fear of
immediate serious bodily injury none
whatsoever that's what he said if you go
and watch the full clip
um also a real matte finish you think i
know there's like a lot of powder
like not even just a glisten under those
lights maybe he's just really
comfortable lying
because here is him two weeks ago the
same same day
what's he saying about tasers charged
with aggravated assault
of uh ms pilgrim and this is for
pointing a taser at mrs uh pilgrimage
as many of you all know on the georgia
law a taser is considered as a deadly
weapon
oh oh oh so the taser was actually aimed
and fired at the officer
no so let me get this straight it's a
it's a deadly it's only a deadly weapon
if well it's not it is if a cop uses it
but it's not if it's aimed at a cup
particularly if it's stolen is there a
property rights argument there
well no
[Laughter]
i mean here here this is one of those
fundamental issues like when you're
making an argument considering what are
the other positions you've taken
and in this particular instance there's
no question that the allegations
of even people that are within the
political party
represented his com the other folks who
are the candidates against other folks
who are in that department saying
wait a minute you literally have just
said this and not just that at once
right maybe he was going to go oh well
two weeks ago i was
wrong when i said it three times at the
same time nobody will remember
no one will remember there's the
internet sir say what say huh
what's his position that that's the law
and he said it multiple multiple
i know i know it's just you can't write
this
you can't write this largely because i
don't have the skill
[Laughter]
and by the way is not
uh at least a weapon not only a deadly
weapon yeah first off it's not a deadly
weapon i don't think that women should
use it to protect themselves from rape
uh because the only thing that maybe
stops a rape is something that's at
least semi-deadly like i like my rape
defenses for my wife at least like
little
at least moderately deadly um not like
ah that's an itch
and if it's not even thr even can cause
serious bodily incapacity to injury
incapacitation
why give it to police officers at all
and by the this is something people
he stole after and one of the officers
has a concussion by the way
the guy was spiked on his head
concussion stole it
then aimed at the cop this is one thing
that the media was watching cnn today
they still keep saying unarmed he wasn't
unarmed no he had the cops taser
and he wasn't shot when he was running
away he was running away
only shot when he turned and aimed the
gun and fired it
and fired it you see the flash in the
video and was obviously very close that
he thought he could uh you know take
some
take
some shooting lessons asked but he was
close enough that he thought he could
hit the officer and what do you think
happens if
this weapon which is designed to
incapacitate goes into it and then he
has access to oh congratulations a
utility belt of deadly weapons
yeah this is this is and i said this
this morning i'm sorry
you cannot at this point be neutral
neutral
people have said silence is racist no at
this point when people say you can save
one life like oh if we could save one
george floyd
you can save one life right now there's
a man there who even if you didn't think
did his job to the best of his abilities
i don't think that he should i don't
even think that he should be suspended
with pay that's just my opinion
doesn't matter what you think the
charges have him facing death
row unless somebody else steps in so
when people if you could save one life
right now everyone can make their voices
heard you can save one life the life of
the officer who protected his buddy who
had his weapon stolen concussed
and aimed at him you want to save a life
let's get rid of the racial thing save
one life right now would have been nice
if we could have known beforehand this
would happen to someone like a david
dorn right who we lost do we never get
back
an actual hero we could say if it saves
one life
it's very rare that we have the
opportunity yeah we have that
long of a fuse to save a life we can do
it right now
not only can we save his life we can
save countless other officers lives
saying look if your life is in danger
you can defend it i don't want you to
hesitate
because you could die right that's what
you do every single day this will cause
other officers to either leave the job
or get shot in a situation where maybe
they could have defended themselves
they're going to think twice about it
now yeah i had videos that i wanted to
show
i don't know officers being no no no
don't laugh because officers are being
shot roadside from oh yeah no
sobriety tests several officers multiple
times after people being tased
you can search it right now and find
them there are more than you could watch
in the span of the show
happens all the time do you know that an
officer is actually 18
times more likely to be shot by a black
criminal
during apprehension than to shoot an
unarmed black man since you're using the
racial crime statistics it does
matter it really does matter when we're
talking about genocide going out and
hunting people this is what i've heard
they've said only on turks they haven't
seen it
they're hunting people and black people
in broad daylight
really but there's an 18 to one ratio of
officers being killed and you want them
defenseless by the way the d is being
investigated for following 140 thousand
dollars
to supplement his salary facing all
these allegations of sexual harassment
and he has a pretty tough primary
challenge i think a runoff right yeah
it's actually moved on to a runoff built
so like
this this charge doesn't seem to make
any sense to anybody that's outside
looking in right he rushed it before the
investigation was over
and it doesn't seem like it's felony
murder no matter how you slice it
how in the world could he justify a
charge like that do you see anything
well
universally being reviled for having
moved too quickly and even to
set a standard where if if you're going
to make a charge now and the charge
isn't going to work
out you're either going to end up with
someone who there is no you know
whether you believe they're justice or
not you're not going to get you're not
going to have any version of justice
when you overcharge someone and you rush
to judgment right right and so
that's the question is we're being
raised right now is was this politically
motivated to
come out ahead of time do it before all
the facts were known before the
investigating body was done
uh to use very aggressive charges even
the new york times today yeah they're
legal
like we're talking about wait a minute
this is way
faster than it should have ever been
considered yeah in this moment and look
i understand that there's a lot
happening in the city but
essentially what you're saying is well
sometimes we're going to rush and just
yeah
rush to misjudgment because people are
screaming
yeah exactly and do we think it's by
design at this point because
what do you think the likelihoods are of
either the charges getting dismissed
or him being found not guilty if you had
a bet i think they're pretty high
yeah a felony murder and so what do you
think is going to happen right yeah
right well on the on the charge of
felony murder
not guilty no justice no peace exactly
and i think he he's definitely doing it
for this runoff he he didn't win the
election he was down by 10 or 12 points
to somebody in his own party that he's
running against
exactly and he is painting this person
as somebody who's more of a republican
the police already don't like this guy
the d.a currently because he arrested
officers in a questionable case before
so now he's just going all in he's like
well the black lives matters movement
right now is in our city i'm going all
in
i'm a man of the people vote for me and
i will take care of bad police officers
that's what he's doing right now and we
have to change my mind's coming up
actually uh
next week specifically on america isn't
racist and we actually had some great
conversations surprisingly
there's a lot of black people who sat
down and uh black liberals who didn't
agree with me but we actually sat down
and found some common ground we
disagreed on the whole idea of some of
the protests and the kneeling
but also uh i was enlightened there were
some new things that i learned about the
black community and they learned some
things about the white community
namely that we're not good dancers and
that you have a large asset no no one
learned that
yeah i'm gonna be honest i just started
doing the assumed the
the father-in-law wedding dance no
there's no assumption necessary there's
significant empirical data
but what does a cop do well we don't
want the cops to have guns okay yeah
well we can't use chokeholds okay which
by the way they reversed in france
france
because they yeah it was too deadly for
officers because they couldn't use
chocolates so no guns no chokes what do
you think they want to do with tasers
now oh they're good at the very least we
don't know is it a deadly weapon is it
not so officers are going to be
scared and i talked about this morning i
would have i would love to start a
just a gofundme for all of these
officers who are walking so they can
have some place to go to i can't do it
but what we will do is create some merch
i think uh either with david dorner and
all proceeds from the merch will go
to funding some kind of a
police-oriented charity so that'll be
there soon and of course uh thin blue
line from black rifle coffee is their uh
they've had it for a long time that goes
supporting law enforcement officials so
um and that's not a commercial i'll talk
about it later but that is if you want
to support police officers because
listen you can't say not all black
people which is correct
and then say but all cops yeah right you
just can't do that because there are a
lot of great police officers out there
and i don't know and i i'm a fan of the
chokeholds of the neck restraints
because i'd rather someone go
unconscious and be cuffed without any
kind of permanent damage
than someone have to go to a gun or a
taser and let me make my case here
what do you guys think of chokeholds
especially people who've never actually
had one applied to them or used it at
all because we're going to actually uh
do it i don't think wade's ever been oh
had a never stray this is good
i won't lie neck restraint sounds more
harmless it does it makes it sound kind
of nice here's what i'll say
it's more uncomfortable than a neck
restraint but less unpleasant than you
would assume a chokehold would be
but you might poop you know
there could be feces yeah okay drink
less coffee like steven seagal instead
of understanding with gene labelle
i think try to punch me little sisters
and i choked him and i guess he didn't
go to the bathroom because
then he went i never go to the bathroom
bad things happen sorry what what
concerns me is is
folks not thinking about what is the
logical conclusion of all this right
like if if we're in a place where
if someone you know there's an attack
there's an officer officers are hurt a
taser is taken a taser is pointed
and at any of those moments essentially
what you said by having the felony
murder charge and saying that some one
of those acts was a felony
is you're saying you shouldn't have done
any of those acts okay right yeah and
what that means is okay fine just say in
that moment we just let this guy go
but you have to create a rule that
applies to all interactions with
officers
so in a moment when an officer has a
suspected dui someone who chose to be in
their vehicle
right and was operating their vehicle in
a dangerous way in a way that we all as
a nation
agree is wrong drunk driving he didn't
by the way the media reported though he
pulled into like he pulled into the
expectant mother's spot
no no no he wasn't just homer simpson at
the nuclear switch into
the drive in the driver's line and so
then then the only answer that cops are
given then is
let everyone go let everyone go and and
say nope go free into the community
hopefully we'll find i wish i knew this
as a skater kid right when cop would
show up like hey stay right there
no and just skate off yeah we actually
respected police yeah absolutely we were
just like oh wait hold on a second
what is the cop gonna do oh yes sorry
we're sorry officer yeah we'll we'll
roll with we'll take the wax off that uh
off that railing yeah but instead i was
like
no drat and i don't know if you saw in
that video
uh when he was before he got all crazy
he was apparently calm and everything
was fine and then
you know the cops tried to do something
they tried to put cuffs on him and
arrest him which is their job
yeah that one of the officers yeah one
of their officers had him in a bit of a
choke hold they had him around the neck
a couple of times and it looked like he
loosened it and tried to move it to the
side
was no it was not a choke at all no
that's what i thought he was trying to
maintain control by using it and then
maybe he had the thought like i can't
use that yeah you can't control someone
with a chokehold actually okay if you
control someone you need to control the
torso the head the hips
and the chokes actually have someone
pass out you know let's go on to the
chokehold thing i've
been so upset about this i have a pit in
my stomach because this man is facing
death doesn't matter what charges you
think
i'm more upset with by the way the
christian conservative right because
you know what we'll just pray from afar
no there's a man who could be put to
death
neutrality is not an option that's not
an option right now okay people and you
see this in all this you know
los angeles and california new york and
like well you know what jesus is just
love
jesus flipped over some tables and if
you want to save a life
you can speak out and help save a life
right now because by all accounts that
we have a could change tomorrow
a good man could be put to death to
appease a mob
of evil people yeah if good men don't
step in and you know what
if you don't step in now when the wolves
are at the door expect us to love you
and pray for you from afar but we're
gonna go
lock lock lock lock bolt
stand up and grow a pair uh by the way
that includes donald trump
yeah that includes all the republican
bootlickers at this point right now
there were riots before we elected you
and there are riots worse now do
something
because i don't know that you deserve
anyone's votes at this point okay
uh let's let's go into the executive
order on chokeholds which of course no
one in this administration actually know
what the arm will talk about about it
as part of this new credentialing
process
choke calls will be banned except if an
officer's life is at risk how do you
determine them
and i will say we've dealt with all of
the various departments
and everybody said it's time
we have to do it so then in this
scenario
in atlanta the officers couldn't have
used a choke hold because they were they
weren't even under threat of bodily
injury
according to the d.a that that's the
craziest part about it is you have to
ignore
all of the physical attack and they call
it tussling right
it's tussling those boys got into a
hooting nanny
it you ha you have to ignore the reality
of the situation and the facts that are
shown on video to say that there wasn't
a threat of physical violence in them
and police officers need better physical
training we'll talk about how to do that
with jack o willing and let me be really
clear a choke people get this wrong like
oh my gosh a chokehold is like drowning
and i'm going to display it uh
later on wade here in a couple of
minutes um it's not at all
and and you can you can understand that
really quickly just by seeing how
quickly
a chokehold or a neck restraint is it's
a vascular neck restraint people use the
term choke it's a
it's it's it's a blood choke it's not a
windpipe choke what we're talking about
here
uh there are windpipe jokes but what
we're talking about is a vascular neck
restraint
do you know okay drowning takes a while
because there's no oxygen you can't
breathe in any oxygen right
right but choke holes vascular neck
restraints can actually work within
seconds here's an example of joe rogan
from i don't know maybe 12 years ago
applying a chokehold so you can see how
quickly someone goes out
yeah you can trust me are you ready
[Music]
ready
keep going right
he's out he's out with you all right man
up dude all right wow
any job yeah two seconds to put them out
put cuffs on them yeah totally fine were
you off your hands
hello you okay do it again
[Laughter]
yeah no it doesn't take long it's not
like drowning let me really
choke it's not a plot one that's not
applied to the windpipe one that's
applied properly it
impedes arterial blood flow right let me
explain it to you in a simple way okay
the brain recognizes the
arterial the blood flow is compromised
sends a message going
oh wait a second and the heart starts
slowing down its pulse
it starts slowing down the blood needed
effectively a chokehold is one of the
very few kinds of techniques that you
can use whereas
a pain hold a submission sometimes the
damage is already being done when
someone feels it if they're on pcp they
have no idea
a chokehold a vascular neck restraint
effectively puts your body into standby
mode
so that it prevents damage yeah so that
you don't drown
for someone of decent health and by the
way that's the same reason you can't use
tranquilizer guns because we don't know
what drugs are in these people there's
no 100
safe way but for someone who doesn't
have a serious condition and even with
people who have more serious conditions
a vascular neck restraint
is undoubtedly more safe than a punch a
strike a baton
a taser if they have a pacemaker a
tranquilizer your body goes
wait a second i'm not gonna get blood i
don't want
actual drowning to happen where there's
brain damage so let's shut everything
down
so that there's as little blood flow and
has a little blood a little oxygen in
the blood
necessary so that i can actually sustain
this
that's the wonder of the vascular neck
restraints you can be put out
never hurt no damage i don't think you
can think of any
people don't just get hit and your body
isn't like oh my gosh i'm going to
uh take a nap to protect you already
have concussive brain damage
yeah by the way hit the speaking of of
damage hit the notification bell hit all
notifications
because subscriptions don't work
notifications don't work on the youtube
we do good morning mug club
weekdays uh monday through thursday at
10 a.m eastern
and of course do join mug club because
uh god knows what's gonna happen to us
after this show
oh i know i know and here's a good exam
and i know that they're trained athletes
but i put this on twitter and i think
we'll have we'll have jocko willing
we've had you know chelsea we've had
daniel cormion
people who compete in striking sports
like boxing kickbox far more likely to
sustain serious
permanent injury or death right you know
you've heard about concussive syndrome
yeah just look at muhammad yeah and we
have i think a source here from uh
academic yeah and then we have another
source from pubmed where um
uh dropping sports chokeholds are
actually much safer
let me get to the studies show that
proper chokehold taught to police rarely
ever fatal
rarely even serious injuries as a matter
of fact according to the brutal police
brutality database run by fatal
encounters
a pro police reform organization less
than one percent
less than one percent of people die from
any form of association
while under any type of restraint during
police encounters
three and a half times more people are
killed by tasers oh
so tasers are addicted to tasers are
significantly more dangerous
than chokeholds and i underst listen but
these are unpleasant scenarios
what you have to do is pick an option
that keeps people as safe as possible
both the perp and the police officer and
there is
right now an actual technique available
that can be used
to render someone entirely incapacitated
without
electrocuting their heart yeah or
rattling their brain around in their
skull
it's a gift and we give it to you
the people it is unreal to me let me ask
you this how many careers have you seen
ended
in boxing or mixed martial arts from a
strike in boxing it used to
i don't know if they cleaned it up it
was like four deaths a year the only
death i think we've seen in a sanctioned
mma about is weight cutting
yeah but many careers have been ended
from strikes repetitive strikes people
have broken their shins
right name me one person who suffered
permanent damage
in any professional fighting sport
sanctioned fighting sport from a
chokehold it's never happened yeah
now people say well it's because you tap
no you can find videos longer than you
could
more footage you could watch in a
lifetime of people going unconscious in
the octagon
yeah now they say well referee steps in
sure that's the point of police training
exactly you don't hold a choke for a
minute if you hold it they go out
cuff them you're done so here and we're
starting at the wrong place when you
talk about safety you start with the
officer's safety first and work from
there
obviously you don't want any anybody
killed or damaged if they don't need to
be if they're a perp but the officer
safety is paramount first they're the
one going after the criminal
yeah are we forget that but their
primary purpose of course is to serve
and protect
us and so a guy driving completely drunk
off his ass or high as a kite
who's running out into civilization and
can do any number of untold damage
afterwards yes
the cops need to subdue that person
absolutely yeah so restrain that but
they have no
they have no way to do it now right
we've taken away all i mean what do we
give him a billy club and say just you
know hit him in the balls i guess i
don't know
good lord sounds good what else are you
going to hit that's a good idea sonny
yeah
see he's that's him on his walk in his
beat hey sonny are you out of school
i hope you don't are you using them
testies for now
not yet ah everyone planning on children
see get back to class you little
riffraff gerald are you running for uh
district attorney on that platform i
i am yeah that's a good platform i'll
tell you what i don't plan on ever
running for office but if i do
i'm going to play that clip non-stop
and this is my secretary of defense
billy club balls billy club balls billy
club balls billy club balls
australian wine and gerald morgan i
present my cabinet have you also seen
that uh
my legal uh secretary of uh what is it
link i don't know
lawyer he's half asian so we're good
we're covered uh you know
you know what let's uh we're gonna we're
gonna take a quick break i'm gonna come
back and show you what a chokehold what
a vascular neck restraint is like and
what it is not
on our very own audio wait or anyone who
wants to take part just a minute we'll
set up right here
[Music]
youtube approved
and trending hitler terrible
holocaust of course six eight million
jews the number that you guys give
absolutely believe it i think it was
great injustice and of course i'm glad
the united states went in with the
axes of evil all of those things hitler
bad zero support
but can stephen really be trusted
just say no to stephen crowder and mug
club
paid for by momskinsmugclub.com
[Music]
hey quick who are you wearing
i'm uh wolverine we need a better budget
for costume
uh it's time to try a chokehold on
weight
all right it's going to be a fun one no
it's just going to show what it is so
first let me show you something that's
really uh somebody
we'll talk about this with jocko in a
minute remember they were stopping to
grab a guy's taser
okay so let me show you before we go to
a chokehold right here there's a taser
you can apply a joint lock but i want to
show you what a joint lock
is so you can see how unpleasant this is
for example so let's say i'm coming in
here i grab that wrist
and i pin wave this is what we know as a
commerce a shoulder lock wade what
you're going to do
is you're going to tap when you start
feeling some pain okay
okay so there you go so uh and i'm not
in proper position right now because we
have a desk behind us but that's
unpleasant that hurts
okay so now i'm gonna sit back up i had
to take my uh boots up no no put your
seat up there
so everyone's gonna say this is gay but
anyone's ever actually applied a choke
knows what this is
i took off my shoes because i didn't
want to hit him in the balls
so typically what happens is a rear
naked choke you see this a lot in mma
i'm trying to control his body here so
this is a good establishing of control
so right
let's say you try and squirm out the
whole reason i'm just controlling
your body here and you have some options
but here see i'm riding you like a
backpack yeah there's an over under grip
now what i want to do let me just show
really quickly i don't want to
choke you on the windpipe okay so if
you're uncomfortable
obviously just tap we'll let it go uh
but i want you to let me know if you can
breathe
okay because a lot of people think it's
like drowning what really happens
is i'm getting his carotid arteries
right here i'm gonna be shutting down
blood flow
okay and there are multiple ways to do
it i can actually do it here with his
collar
this is called a bow and arrow choke so
see look at this you can even see my
forearm is not
on his throat right you can see that's
not but i can
cut off the blood circulation that way
there are a million different ways but
the most common is what's called the
rear naked choke so
what i'm going to do is grab weight here
okay put this under his chin i don't
want to get i don't want to get a zipper
on you sure yeah
you know it's better than a taser to the
heart that's true
or the balls yeah but you electrify my
heart
oh that's sweet so wait don't worry the
segway is called let's kill away
uncomfortable
so what i'm going to do here is put them
in a chokehold and if any of you
have questions you can ask i'm going to
grab my own bicep my own shoulder the
idea here
is to close the space around his neck as
much as i can
so a lot of people get this wrong if
they're not trained properly what
they'll do is they'll grab this
and they'll jerk it right i had one
trainer who called uh called this
for some reason i don't know why the uh
the captain america and the wolverine i
don't know what uh
so let me show you kind of really
quickly if you can come here man your
show let's say this is wade's head right
here
here just now for one second let's see
this is wade's head okay
the goal is to close the space this is
his throat
my elbow is ideally right where his
throat is so that's the least
amount of pressure being applied is
right on his trachea if i'm doing it
correctly
but i want to squeeze the sides of his
neck so here's all the space for weights
head right now
close it okay there's a little less
space right close that now what i do is
put this on my shoulder
a little less space hit imagine his head
right here in my chest bring this around
there's a little less space something
else i do
breathe in there's a little less space
then i squeeze everything together i
don't yank
that's how you miss a choke that's why
you see some guys who can be choked for
a long time they don't go out
what i want to do here is get my head on
this side and
close that space look at that space
right there how much space is there for
weight's head
not a whole lot but it's thrilled
and so i'm assuming it'll actually be
applied more quickly yeah
so wade what i want to do is start
applying it and i'm going to apply so my
goal is not to make you go unconscious
but
if it doesn't hurt you know you don't
have to tap because it's not going to be
painful if you do go outside i just want
to get rid of the zipper here
now what i'm going to do is do me a
favor since just
let's point your throat so it's right in
the nook of my elbow turn to the right
there you go right there okay just for
right now
now what i'm going to do is slowly uh
apply some pressure and i want you to
tell me if you can breathe
okay okay
how can you breathe yep okay now can you
breathe
a little bit less yeah now what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna apply the pressure
to the point
that you could go unconscious and you
can tap but i want you to tell me if
it's because you can't breathe okay
tap his foot if you need to go out
just raise his feet up this is what we
do so we get some you good blood flow
back
yeah do you know that you went
unconscious uh it makes sense
are you good yeah i'm fine could you
breathe it wasn't waterboarding at all
no no no
do you feel like you were drowning no
did it hurt your neck
no i didn't know if you could thank god
for the audience there yeah i don't know
i could
i felt it and see right away i kind of
felt okay he's going out
sure and that happened he came out and
by the way that's not a seizure or
anything that's literally his body going
up just wake him up power up from
standby mode you're good
yep thanks for being a champ about it
nice see didn't even
by the way he would not have been able
to do that if i crush his windpipe
sure you drown there's no way like oh
that's okay i can't breathe and all of
us have had this done to us who've done
brazilian jiu jitsu so go find your
local instructor
uh speaking of which i think we have to
go to jocko i'm gonna buy this man of
beer
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
if you're listening on audio you're
probably wondering what's happening
right now
if you're not listening on audio
subscribe at apple podcasts google play
and spotify
ran away
[Music]
all right our next guest have to be
careful the cliff dysmanius
he thinks he's very territorial he
always thinks i'm inviting his territory
and he is one hell of an energy drink i
haven't had it because i hate pina
coladas
uh no i have had it actually our next
guest and he just asked me about the
energy drinks and i will say this i
always try to be straightforward like
with black rifle coffee i don't like the
the black beard because i don't like
dark roasts this is my favorite coffee
i was only given a pina colada tasting
energy drink
which i think anything with coconut and
pineapple tastes like suntan lotion i
mean
um like i don't want to taste it like to
me anything that has that flavor it
tastes like they cleaned up the bar at
sandals
and put it in a cup so uh
that being said uh that's just perfect
but i have heard that all the flavors
are great and people here who love
that flavor so it's the best so i'm
looking forward to getting other flavors
of course you know him you love him he
was uh
on joe rogan's show recently so a lot of
people have been asking for him you can
follow more at jackopodcast.com he has
his own show
mr jocko willing how are you sir what's
happening
well i just kind of filled you in on
that but i can rehash it if you like
you're going to send non-pina colada
flavored energy yes
i'll send you the uh i'll send you the
psycho citrus it's kind of like a lemon
lime deal or the
dak savage which is like a what is it
cherry vanilla dark black cherry vanilla
oh i like cherry
yeah well what's your favorite the
tropical
uh no my favorite is actually citrus
psycho it's like a lemon lime scenario
do you find it so do you find it
difficult sometimes to have to keep
track like through your sort of rolodex
of what the flavor actually is versus
what the
jocko brand has to title it you know
what look it'd be really cool if i could
have called the pina colada one just
pina colada because that's what it
tastes like
and uh but the bottom line is i couldn't
call it pina colada
yeah that's like a girl's drink in a in
a tropical place right
not happening here right well way to cut
out 50 of your market share
women need not drink chocolate energy
apparently it's not something to do with
fertility i don't know
um so jocko listen it's no secret
obviously that uh that you were a navy
seal and you've trained um with a lot of
some of the most high level operatives
in the world
and you've been talking about police
recently and this is a hot topic
right right now obviously with police
brutality versus training versus
solutions some people are calling for
defunding the police
the very first thing i said when this
story came out i think where everyone
agreed with george floyd and chauvin
that it was
wrong that we need i said we need better
training first off we can get to the
unions in a little bit but we need
better training because a lot of these
officers
they have to go to their tool belt right
they get very little time
um in unarmed hand-hand combat training
and so it's hard to de-escalate
if you have to go to a tool that
escalates it and of course
you've worked with these people more
closely give us some insight here as to
to what you think some of the solutions
may be and what kind of training a
police officer gets
right now when they go out there into
the field so right now
they get a sustainment training for what
they call defensive tactics or
combatives and what those two things
combine together what they mean is how
do you arrest somebody how do you put
hands on someone
it includes some of their weapons
retention skills so it's a huge amount
of
of knowledge that a person should have
and they get about two to four hours
on average a year a year
and they're supposed to be proficient in
this stuff it's it's it's not even
remotely close to the amount of training
that they need my suggestion that i'm
trying to
tell people all over the place is i
think police officers should spend
one-fifth of their time training
one-fifth of their time training so
you know eight hours a week out of a
40-hour week one day a week maybe two
hours a day what
however you want to skin it but you need
to do this training all the time
you know we used to spend 18 months
in training preparing to go on
deployment and then we go on deployment
for six months
and we come back we would train again
police officers there they
they get this little tiny fraction of
training so that's that's what they need
to start doing
and hopefully if they do that people
become more comfortable the more
confident you are the more comfortable
you are handling people the more
capable you are of handling people the
more
varying degrees you can use to apply
force and get people
under control because if you don't have
the capability of getting someone under
control with your hands well then you're
using weapons
right and and and if you fail with your
first weapon you're going to your second
weapon
and usually for police officers their
second weapon is a pistol
and someone's getting killed right so
it's not a good situation
right now and it's certainly something
we need to focus on as a country well
you're touching a couple things there i
think you're right it is it's a no one
is denying that this is an intense job
but we're not treating it the same as
other intense jobs like you just
mentioned you know if you're on a tour
of duty
or for example take any sport you can
take obviously strong men they might
compete a few times a year
hockey players have a season basketball
players have a season and then police
officers
they don't have a season of training
with a short burst of performance
they have performance performance
performance with very little upkeep and
training
and maybe that's an important component
to this is shifting that mindset people
are saying shifting the mindset to
de-escalation shifting the mindset to
social workers instead of police
but we first maybe need to shift the
mindset to understanding how intense
this can be and
what the capabilities are like you're
saying for for output do you think it
maybe is somewhere between what we have
and what exists in the military middle
ground but it should be closer to
more training like a military operative
not not the same kind of missions
but the level of training yeah it's
definitely not the same kind of missions
but
yeah we need to lean in that direction
the bottom line is the military is an
extreme version of training
for sure and they don't need that much
training because they're working all the
time
but to do basically zero training or one
percent of your time training is totally
ridiculous
yeah the hodge twins came in actually
and they were both marines and uh
they said they never we took them in the
range and said we never fired a pistol
they said they gave us an m16 said aim
it downrange um and they said we never
really had done hand-to-hand combat
training they said it really varies
in different branches of the military
it's specialized um and i'm sure you
probably have a remark about the marines
since you're a navy seal right something
like village people
no i would say the marines are
outstanding and i work with the marine
corps and they're
just some of the most professional
people you'd ever want to work with
drink jackal energy
so uh let me ask you about speaking of
escalating
the french the this brings us to the
idea of chokeholds because
we don't want police officers right now
or a lot of people are calling for
defunding okay that's an extreme example
but it is
it is a black lives matter movement
right now their leadership call is to
totally abolish and defund the police
scale it back
defunding the police diverting those
funds to social workers
or workers who have non-lethal force
at all as part of their protocol then
scale that back a little bit you know we
end up with
okay maybe we get rid of guns from
police officers that's a call but then
i've also seen after
rayshard brooks we shouldn't have tasers
and now this general idea
no chokeholds well france just reversed
that i don't know if you've been
following this they just reversed their
ban on children
i'm not really up on the the french news
but you can fill me in what have you
ever
have you uh you're out in the military
you ever have any french french
people there french allies out there i
never i never work we do work with a
friend sometimes i never work with the
french
yeah i i i didn't know if they come with
a i'm french canadian i don't know if
they come with a standard issue white
flag
but canadians did go obviously into
afghanistan and a lot of places and um
uh some great soldiers come out of
canada just not nearly as many of them
as you have in the united states
uh but the french just reversed it they
just reversed a ban on chokeholds so it
was banned and they reversed it because
the french police argued
that uh the ban put their lives at risk
and there is some evidence coming out
now that it
actually resulted in more lethal forms
of force so i think sometimes when
people say
ban chokeholds do you think they really
know what they're asking
for they 100 don't know what they're
asking for banning chokeholds is
is a horrible idea and
when you think about what you need to do
to make someone comply and you can't use
a chokehold chokehold is the absolute
best way to get someone to comply it's
it's safe 99.9 percent of the time
you know you and i do being jiu jitsu
players we've choked
thousands of people and been choked
thousands of times
and i've never been hurt from a
chokehold i've never heard someone from
a chokehold ever thousands and thousands
and thousands of repetitions
and here's the deal if i want to subdue
you and i'm not allowed to choke you
guess what i have to do i have to hit
you i have to hit you in the head and i
have to hit you in the head usually with
an object and this is if i'm not
shooting you right so i pull out my
baton and i start hitting you in the
head
i have seen individuals take
you know four five eight shots to the
head
with batons or with weapon strikes and
be perfectly fine
and keep finding maybe not be perfectly
fine but they keep fighting they keep
fighting
and finally you have to beat someone
until they stop i think rodney king is a
great example that rodney king
a chokehold would have been would have
been there would have been no video
there would be no riots nothing
somebody would have known what to do
there they would have gone and put
rodney king to sleep
cuffed him put him in the back of the
car you'd have been fine instead the
only thing those cops knew how to do
was hit him in the head well hitting
someone in the head just like when you
watch a boxing match
how often does someone in a boxing match
actually get knocked out right it
doesn't happen that often
yeah why because it's hard to knock
someone out right
how often when you get a choke on
someone they're going to sleep that's
all there is to it
and the great thing is once you let go
of the choke
they wake back up they're perfectly fine
there's no brain trauma
they're not marked up it's it's the best
way to subdue
subdue someone and to take that skill
set away from the cops
is a big mistake well here's kind of an
extreme example to to make a point
anyone out there okay let's say you have
to fight you have to fight until it's
finished with mike tyson okay anyone
else out there
how do you think that ends up now you
have to fight until a finish with jocko
willink
jocko willing can end that fight without
anyone ever so much as having a scratch
because of the tools that you go to um a
lot of people don't understand that they
don't understand the limit of tools
that's why we see so much damage in
boxing too and it's because of the
training where you're limited in your
tools and you're hitting the head
non-stop and i think a lot of people
don't i mean you just had nancy pelosi
say that
police chokeholds are a moderate she
said it was a lynching those were the
words that she used
a lynching how worrisome is that when
you have elected officials go out who
people believe are authority
authoritative on the subject basically
accusing our police of using
arguably i'll leave some room here
arguably one of the most peaceful ways
to end a physical altercation
with a hate crime
well luckily she's not doesn't sound
like she's trying to stir anything up
with that comparison
mad about that yeah that's just it's
just it's just ridiculous that's
completely ridiculous
um you know if if someone if my
one of my kids or or if me if i was
going to get arrested i want to get
arrested by people that know jujitsu
because they're going to come in they're
going to do it with the minimum force
required that's what you want police
officers to do
and and again if you don't train people
and you just have people
learn to choke hold and that's it you
know then you're not really you're still
not doing them justice it's
we need to do a you know full systemic
change in the way we're training our
police officers
police being a police officer is a
freaking hard job
every single day and you don't know if
you're going to have
you don't know if the person you're
pulling over is a mom that's with kids
in the back going to soccer or if that's
a person with a pistol
or that's going to assault you and try
and kill you you don't know
and that's what you live with every
single day so for us not to put them in
those situations with the right tool
to handle every one of those different
situations is completely
it's completely wrong for for america to
do that to our police officers right now
and as people see in france it ends up
it potentially could end up harming far
more people just like a professor at
harvard
um just as just came out yesterday where
he said you know defunding the police
would
it would result in thousands of more
black lives being lost
because of police not protecting uh
other black citizens who often need it
the most so
when we go to the web extended i'd like
to talk a little bit more about
specifically kind of chokeholds and our
experiences with those but let me ask
you this
in general with this subject the law and
order at large
and the riots and protests in every
major city by the way every major city
have turned into riots some small ones
and smaller towns or suburbs have been
peaceful
um where do you think this is what i
will say i've never
looking at chas i've never in my
lifetime ever been one of those people
who's feared a potential
some kind of incarnation of a civil war
but when i look at a place like chas
and uh as a military officer i'd be
curious as to
your point of view and people take over
an american city they're shaking down
business owners you have to present id
to come or leave in what's supposedly a
free country and they're protecting it
with guns
i go gosh i'm not saying i would like
but i wouldn't be surprised if the
citizens who live there and business
owners
try and take back their rights with guns
and i've never
been afraid of that in my country of
that escalating um what do you think of
where we are at large here and how it
compares to like actual wars that you've
been in
yeah i think the major thing that you're
lacking is any level of commitment from
the people in there
you know look you're not a big fan of
razz the warlord
rasmussen it seems like kind of a cool
like hey
you know you want to tell that story
over you know you know in a couple
months be like oh yeah
i was in jazz and what was it called
chas
now it's chop yeah i was in chop i was
in chop yeah
but when there's it's like if we were
gonna actually go in there and take them
and fight them and
peop like the the police force showed up
ready to do battle like those people be
like yeah yeah yeah we're good
we're good okay yep look a little riot
thing's over we're good where are we
going there's no commitment in there
it's you know it's it'll be over do you
think so
yes um i hope so i hope so but i i do
worry when you have citizens who
have effectively you know mayors and and
governors who haven't done anything you
have business owners or people who live
there who didn't vote for this and they
can't get to and from their houses
or run their own businesses right now
that's got to be hell for those people
and it only takes one person to react
which at this point my point is
people look at i don't think it's
irrational for someone to react
in a severe way who's living in this
sort of occupied area right now and
there are many of them yeah
and i guess my point is when those
people react the
the people that are in chas
will uh they'll they'll just be like oh
yeah sorry like i mean if they did that
in my neighborhood
this thing wouldn't have happened what
do you mean can you explain that
well you're not gonna block off my my my
house where i live
my property and tell me i can't go in
there or to come to my house and think
you're going to extort money from me
that's not happening why not
what does jekyll willing to do
you're you're just you're not going to
do that i'm going to walk outside
hey are you a lawyer right now is this a
i think i can guess um talk it over some
some non-pinnacle what's it called uh
pineapple uh
citrus weed no just so i think there's
some people and and you know what
hey you wanna show up here you're gonna
act tough okay cool we got it we
understand
uh oh wait wait a second now you're
actually gonna try and try and
try and take something from my business
no that's not happening
right that's not happening and i think
when people realize that that's not
happening
what what what what members of antifa
are ready to
ready to really try and bring it where's
the numbers
they're not trying to bring but they
want to you know put on a football a
lacrosse helmet
and and come and like try and you know
throw something at my house okay i get
it you know i'll shoot you the paintball
gun and we'll have some fun
that's fine right if you're trying to
like infringe on my property and try and
come and harm my family
they're not ready to make those kind of
commitments yeah i think you're right
until it becomes a mob of people and
those individuals become afraid of
speaking out and i hope that's not
what's happening
but i'm afraid that it might be
happening down there with some people
when they're outnumbered um
all right listen we're going to go to it
is the jockopodcast.com
where can the energy drink be uh
purchased there jacob before we go to
web extended
you can go to on amazon you can do
origin main dot com
and yeah that's where you can get it
origin main all right we are going to
web extended for those are my club
members if you're not well
sorry this is where it gets
[Music]
just thinking about it makes me mad all
y'all out here that didn't join mug club
not join them keeps you from living up
to your full potential
it'll hold you back
louderatecrowder.comclub
i suggest it to you your friends and
your family
i think we need to eliminate people
can stephen really be trusted
just say no to stephen crowder and mug
club
paid for by momskinsmugclub.com
do you exclusively shop in dumpsters
you do don't you
you look like a homeless man's ass rag
a look only a raccoon would love is this
what a stroke is
pure unadulterated disappointment
personified in clothing
but lucky for you i have a solution
ladderwithcrowdershop.com
now that's what i'm talking about you'll
be beating the women away with a stick
looking that good
beguile your potential mates with your
sheer masculinity
become the envy of all your friends
while showing off
those legs heck you're downright rugged
unfortunately for you it doesn't correct
crippling anxiety
cover your bits and tackle with silky
smooth ranger panties
at lotterycrowdershop.com
[Music]
all right it's getting toward what's not
really the end of the week it's just
tomorrow then we have to do all the
updates and everything
a couple of things the extended
interview this week we didn't do it with
jaco because he had an appointment
yeah so we did have to pre-take the
interview as you know and then uh
so there's one week we don't but then we
are going to talk about our first choke
out stories
and of course to reiterate the the lady
who modeled aunt
jemima you want to fact check it's just
we couldn't not do it
it was just too fun it's too fun it's
too fun to think that it's actually
one's biological like the 23 in me says
i don't know
aunt jemima yeah she may have been an
aunt she could have been an aunt
who knows who knows i mean everyone has
brothers and sisters
particularly i'm sure people who call
each other brothers and sisters that's
true
the only people who do that are black
people and those at the convent
so audio wait how explain for people who
don't you know by the way
everyone who hasn't ever been choked
everyone's ever done jiu jitsu
judo grappling has been choked many many
times uh but usually people don't when
it's the first time you're a real
trooper you went out there on your on
your shield what was it like
totally fine yeah not even really
uncomfortable um
yeah just like waking up and you had a
little dream
it's like a little dream state it's like
a little dream that i wasn't being
arrested
right yes exactly well it's important to
dream yeah
um and if you were a perp would you
rather have that or a taser
that yeah i think you'd rather than that
i would do when i when i have ever
actually had like been submitted or
anything in competition i'm like oh
i just hope it's a joke sure sometimes
you walk up to this crazy guy
who's really strong like oh just don't
want to get a hold of my arm or my knee
you're like oh okay
yeah then i just take a quick nap and
i'm good even if he's mad at me
i know i'll be fine uh matter of fact in
mma it's pretty common like the dia i
think the ds brothers
and if you tap to choke you and [ __ ] as
they say because it's kind of like
fight as long as you can and i think
it's silly if you're just taking a choke
but you don't take a long nap you don't
keep going if it's your arm because
people get their arms snapped or their
knees snapped but
no one who's sane would be willing to go
through that so what you're saying is
i'm like the diaz brothers
you are looking at the ds it's hard man
what is it three one
was it 303 what is their area code
stockton someone tell me this
stockton area code uh i'm pretty sure
they don't live there now
they have floors um we have big shows
next week big mug club big uh change my
mind and then a special announcement uh
for uh
thursday live stream yeah uh and of
course just so you know we will be
streaming we will be doing shows through
the week of the fourth of july
and then it's our summer break for uh
until the first week
of august and that's just because we
have a lot of stuff to do here behind
the scenes we do that for like two or
three weeks at christmas and two or
three weeks in the summer so that we can
update everything
and uh some holes in the roof so i do
have to get going let me tell you we
were planning at one point an event in
dc
we can let the cat out of the bag
because we're not doing it now yeah
because everyone at this team was
convinced there was no way for us to do
it and me not get shot
uh yeah and the idea was to do a segment
there of
kneeling for prayer and standing for the
pledge of allegiance
um for it to not be a political event um
because i don't believe that any of our
solutions right now in this country and
and
and i haven't said this before man like
when people used to say oh
obama's ruined the country i said well
you know listen you get the next one and
you fight where you can and this is this
is a bad law
but we have a system of checks and
balances this is the first time that
i've i've feared some kind of like
legitimate civil uprising or civil war
because i think civil wars don't really
look like
civil wars don't exactly look like
people think they look
if it's your neighborhood and people are
taking it over like chaz or chop but i'm
gonna keep calling it chaz because i
want them to face the legal liability of
yes jazz right if it's your neighborhood
you're going home or like my wife right
now who has some
health issues and i need to be helping
her and you walk home and there are some
antibodies with masks trying to shake
you down to go into your house saying
you can't go in your house because
you're taking this over
oh okay let me get my wallet bang bang
bang bang bang click open the door
reload bang bang bang bang that's the
end of it
no one's stopping me from getting into
my house to protect my wife does that
make someone an extremist
i'm not talking about going out hunting
people of course not
but is it really so outlandish to think
that when people are being controlled
by unelected mobs in entire blocks
with guns that they end up taking back
their rights as american citizens with
guns
well they should move no one has a right
to force someone to move
at gunpoint and so we didn't do the
event in dc i'll tell you why um
i think that obviously uh we can't find
our solutions
through identifying through one's race
as a christian the only way we can solve
our issues here is
to stop looking at the color of one's
skin to stop looking at things that are
superficial and start looking to god and
i think we do need to pray together and
i think it's really important though
at this point for christians to step up
and instead of trying to
where's the church where is the church
do you have pastors right now who won't
even host
service in their own congregations
while billions of dollars in damage
have been caused in cities was 25
million in the first week in minneapolis
right do we have does anyone have a
total yet what has been done across the
country no sir
i think we're in the athlete probably a
little smaller than new york
times it by eight thousand somewhere in
the billion range
and the church and their churches are
doing zooms
it's unreal to me no one mentions if the
if the virus uptake you know and the
death count hasn't gone up with it so
obviously some testing comes into
account there no one mentions we
we blame congregations for choir
practice
but not people screaming at other folks
to kneel and here's the thing a lot of
people are trying to accuse folks of
being racist for
not kneeling um figuratively i want our
leaders
republicans included to stop kneeling
and literally
no american should kneel to another man
none it's not a symbol of unity it's a
symbol of cowardice
you do not kneel if you're a black man
you
never kneel to another black man or a
white man if you're a white person
you don't kneel too i have to list all
the colors otherwise people say i'm
singing what
uh red white yellow taupe
your guess is as good as mine with the
dolz owls and boltons and
michael jackson's i don't know include
all the colors of the rainbow and even
ones that people will technically try
and hang me on because they're not
colors they're shades
you don't bow to any human being but
we've lost sight of that because we have
lost sight of
what we are as a country who say oh we
had slavery well you know you know what
yeah we did have slavery and we fought a
really bloody war to end slavery
we had hundreds of thousands of slaves
in the united states there are still six
million slaves in africa
there are still many many millions of
slaves in the middle east you know who
else had slaves by the way muhammad
now i know you'll say oh that was a
different time just like in the united
states do they still have slaves in the
middle east today
near a slave to be found in qatar
clock boy with your phillips and a
suitcase tell me about the slave trade
over there
but we sweep so we did end slavery and
the reason we ended slavery was because
we thought
we knew that it was irreconcilable with
the constitution the declaration of
independence with the idea that all men
are created equal
from the very beginning if you look at
the writings of george washington of
jefferson
they all had a problem with it it was
changing a process stopping a train that
was in motion a locomotive from a very
very long time before
it and we got there and it's terrible
that we did it
understood but that's also why we don't
kneel
the reason we ended slavery is for the
same reason that you don't kneel today
because no christian is to kneel to
anyone
ever matter of fact i know some people
they go on the bible
you can read instances about every
instance you reap where someone kneels
to anyone other than god including
angels
and what are you doing i should have
said don't no
don't don't kneel to me the big guy's
gonna see don't kneel to me
that's throughout the entire bible and
we stand
at the pledge of allegiance why we stand
to
honor the flag of the country the only
country
in human history that was founded on the
promise that we would never have to
kneel to a man
again and it took us a while to make
sure that happened with everybody
to end the slave trade but the idea of
kneeling
before a human being is deeply
anti-christian just that it is
deeply anti-american and for someone to
try and reappropriate something
that could you imagine if we just said
well no now i'm gonna bend over and
i'm gonna bend down and face mecca five
times a day uh and i'm gonna do it
because um
i would like socialize healthcare you
can't just
change something that's symbolic and
what it means
because you have a grievance no matter
how legitimate it is
americans should not kneel i don't
respect
a man who kneels to men literally
or figuratively and it bothers me when
you have christians well
you know we're going to kneel because it
shows a shows a sign of unity that's not
what it does man
it shows a sign of subservience and it
shows a sign of subservience when you do
with black lives matter you can see
these videos right now
entirely based on your race
that's as close to modern slavery in
america as you get
listen listen you're white kneel
well why because white because white
privilege
you're demanding that someone kneel to
you in subservience
as though you are a god because of their
race
at the same time where we might
sacrifice a man
at the altar of political correctness
with officer rolfe that's what that is
that's not a man who deserves to die
he's facing the death penalty
we have gotten so far off the beam in
this country
i couldn't care less if someone wants to
throw out a false accusation
of kneeling being a just like this being
a sign of white supremacy
don't tell the home alone 2 dvd box set
and so we're at the point where you know
i don't necessarily agree with what
i do agree this country needs healing
and the only way to heal is obviously
through god through our christian
principles
but i also think that there's a time
where a shepherd needs to protect their
flock
and chaz is a great example and this
officer is a great example we can save
lives now
we can liberate people and that's the
promise of this country and it's being
infringed upon
and it is unbelievable to me that those
in leadership republican and democrat
aren't protecting
the very rights upon which this country
was founded
i'm trying to see what we have for next
week
um i've changed my mind
i don't know
i don't care you know what kneel if you
want stand if you want i guess
that's the point you have the right to
do it
you have the right to do whatever it is
that you want if you want to kneel
out of guilt fine
demanding that another man kneel
is not just offensive
uh as an american because i don't want
to you know be like gerald and murder uh
it's not just offensive to the american
sensibilities and by the way if you're
an
edgy atheist in the comment section
that's totally fine you enjoy the
inalienable birthrights as protected
by government given by god that's
something a lot of people miss too right
the same reason that we don't kneel is
because we recognize in this country
that our rights are given to the only
person to whom we kneel which is god
the government doesn't grant rights and
that's something that's really pretty
people think is benign in germany just
recently they destroyed
they made a internet human right oh well
that sounds nice i like internet sprint
sucks
got it but what happens if what happens
if the government is the one who tells
you
oh internet is right we're just granting
rights
i guess we can take it away and you see
that with sheriffs
or mayors across this country or we're
going to take away their right
to defend themselves you can just take
away you just give and take away rights
i'm not telling you that you can't ever
kneel let's be clear about that what i
am telling you is that you should never
be
called to kneel before any other man
because of what the constitution
promises black
white red yellow and that doesn't exist
in other countries
it doesn't exist in the continent of
africa where you still have enslavement
based on race by the way
between tribes where it still exists in
the middle east where still exists in
asia based on where you're from slavery
is still a thing and people do kneel and
it's not a symbol of
unity it's because they're forced to
if you kneel put on some shackles while
you're at it
and if you're a leader who kneels don't
expect the vote
of myself and i can't speak for everyone
here but i'm pretty sure
that you can expect to forgo the vote of
anyone here at louder with crowder we'll
see you next week and neil if you want
not just uh
i just think you're a [ __ ]
[Music]
next
[Music]
next
[Music]
away
[Music]
one time yeah